[Musique]
comme un air de jeux olympiques ce
weekend au golfe national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les personnes
qui font avec nous bah écoutez je compte
sur vous pour applaudir des athlètes
René je te laisse la parole pour
présenter le show de tombline à quelques
mois des JO 2024 une journée olympique
était organisée par la Communauté
d'Agglomération au programme
démonstration et découverte d'une
trentaine de sports parmi eux escalade
golf BMX ou encore tumbling une
discipline non olympique mais qui
appartient à la Fédération Française de
Gymnastique l'occasion de découvrir une
nouvelle discipline
du grand public donc moi mon but à long
terme c'est de pouvoir vraiment faire
connaissance que tout le monde quand on
parle de Tony on dit ah oui je sais ce
que c'est la connaissance de ce sport a
évolué dans mon but c'est vraiment de
démocratiser ce sport et montrer que
voilà c'est un sport à part entière et
qui peut être pratiqué n'importe où
Paris réussi pour le scotch la
performance attire et impressionne le
public c'est vraiment impressionnant
c'est très très beau à regarder et ça
doit être très très difficile à faire
les figures étaient très
belles toute la journée les visiteurs
ont pu échanger avec les sportifs et
s'initier aux différentes disciplines de
quoi susciter l'engouement des Yvelines
à l'approche des Jeux ah non des jeux je
sens un grand au moment du public et des
50 chinois je le sens au quotidien par
un succès comme une journée comme
aujourd'hui mais je le sens également
par les nombreuses très nombreuses
candidatures au titre du volontariat
vous savez que Saint-Quentin a réussi à
négocier que Paris 2024 le fait de
réserver plus de 1000 postes pour les
volontaires issus du territoire et bien
nous avons aujourd'hui plus de 4 fois
plus de candidats que nous n'avons de
postes ouverts on a aux environs de
presque 5000 candidats qui se sont
portés volontaires pour rejoindre le
mouvement olympique à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines une journée
qui permet donc de commencer à arriver
et peut-être de créer des vocations chez
des futurs champions agit moins 396 de
la cérémonie d'ouverture
[Musique]